(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
- All right, we are almost out of time.
Give it up for my band, y'all, real quick!
(audience cheering)
Yay!
We are almost out of time,
but there's just enough
for one more great story.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Check out this adorable stuffed elephant.
Come on, her name is Baby Chaba,
and she's named after a
real-life elephant in Thailand.
The real Baby Chaba was rescued from abuse
thanks to the efforts of many activists,
including a California
mama who created this doll.
And proceeds from this plushie
are helping rescue even more
elephants, which is so cool.
Let's get this super mama in here.
Say hi to Kristina,
watching on KSBY in the
lovely Santa Barbara.
What's up, Kristina?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly, thanks so much for having me.
- Hi, so how long have
you been doing this work?
- So I started over 20 years ago.
I actually saw a baby
elephant being abused
in the streets of Thailand,
and this was before social
media or anything like that.
So I was distraught by it and I was like,
"I can't not unsee this," once
you see something like that.
So I came back from Santa Barbara
and I started protesting
circuses and signing petitions,
but it just didn't feel like enough.
And I think when you have a
calling so strongly like this,
you have to do something.
And so I saw my daughters one day
playing with stuffed animals
and I decided to use my background
in product development and design
and create a stuffed animal
to help raise funds
and awareness for them.
So that was kind of my goal.
I knew that the girls
were kind of the most
affected by the abuse,
and I really wanted to
teach children everywhere
that one person can make a difference
and that we all need to be
the voice for the voiceless.
- Absolutely, and when you see something,
you can be part of the
change to make that happen.
I love that.
So this is also about educating everybody,
but including kids, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
I think it's so important to
teach the younger generation.
And so, you know, it started
just as a philanthropic toy company,
but I've started to
teach children in Africa
about how it's so important to
be friendly to the elephants
and nice to them,
and why it's important
for their environment.
And it's so important to teach them
that elephants are really
emotional creatures.
That's the book I wrote for Lek Chailert
with my friend Pedro de la
Cruz here in Santa Barbara.
But I wanted people everywhere to know
that we shouldn't ride
them or exploit elephants,
and I thought I'd start with the children.
And I'm super grateful for the
momentum and all the support.
- Oh man, this is incredible
work you're doing.
And so important, because a
lot of times we do see things
and we don't know what to do.
So it's important to know
that you can actually
be a part of like positive change.
And I think it's smart
to start with the kids,
'cause then at a very young age
they learn a respect for animals,
and then, you know, maybe
don't become the adults
that we have around us today sometimes.
So teach them to be better than us.
Thank you so much, Kristina.
I'm liking your post right now.
I love little Chaba.
And that's not all,
our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of the G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 to use to continue
your incredible work.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much
for joining us from the
lovely Santa Barbara.
That place is so awesome.
But thank you to all our
guests, this hour as well,
Taylor and Taylor Lautner, Alex Astor,
Asi Wind, Jackie and Jay Brown.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.